[Music]
it's a fruit known by many names cactus
pear cactus fruit and prickly pear it
grows on several species of cacti which
are native to parts of North Central and
South America some growers in addition
to selling the fruit produce a puree
which they sell as a flavoring prickly
pear martini anyone cactus pear fruit is
high in fiber and rich in vitamins and
minerals it's sweet and delicious eaten
as is or as a natural flavoring in foods
and beverages in the Salinas Valley in
California the cactus pear harvest
begins around late August and continues
through early April the fruit is right
when it's skin begins turning red the
harvesters wear thick leather gloves to
protect their hands from the thorns and
safety glasses to shield their eyes from
loose thorns that blow through the air
tractors haul the cactus pears to the
processing plant the fruit first passes
over brushes and into a vacuum that
removes loose dirt then through a shower
of chlorinated water which kills off
bacteria the fruit enters a cold air
dryer for about five seconds then passes
through a hot air dryer for 20 seconds
the fruit X is completely dry a
quality-control team removes any with
bruises or other cosmetic defects and
transfers those cactus pears to the pure
a-line the fruit that passes inspection
falls into what's called a sink you
later
a machine that lines them up in
single-file the cingulate ER deposits
each cactus pear into a cup on a
computer-guided way in sort machine
which classifies each fruit by size then
applies the growers price code sticker
the fruit then travels on the conveyor
belt that leads to the pad and tub
designated for its weight classification
a worker stationed at the tub packs the
cactus pears into a lined shipping box
another worker removes any less than
perfect fruit that managed to slip
through the previous checks those also
go to the puree line on the puree line
the dumper drops the cactus pears onto a
conveyor belt system which transports
them to the crusher
the machine crushes the fruit separating
the skins and flesh mashing the flesh
into puree and extracting the sweet
magenta color juice from the crusher the
pressed skins drop onto the vibrating
shaker while the puree and juice flow
through it into a tank below the shaker
separates any puree still caught in the
skins the skins drop into a bin and are
hauled off to be used as compost or sold
as animal feed once the tank is filled
to capacity with about 400 pounds of
puree a pump transfers it to a large
hopper a worker releases pure ray from
the hopper to the finisher the finishers
find screens trap the seeds while
letting the puree pass through to a
holding tank below the seeds are sold to
businesses that press them into oil for
cosmetic and hair products from the
holding tank the deseeded puree passes
through a second finisher with even
finer filters
then it flows into a tank for
pasteurization which kills off any
remaining bacteria the puree is finally
ready
a worker fills a drum which is double
lined with plastic bags she draws for
one cup samples from each drum for
quality control tracking once a drum
contains 400 pounds of puree the workers
zip ties each bag separately closes the
drum with the lid safety seals the lid
with the lock then puts the drum in the
freezer the cactus pear puree is sold
frozen to the food and beverage industry
which uses it to flavor many products
from ice cream sorbet and gelato to
flavored water wine tequila and brandy
you
[Music]